first of all welcome to the mtv movie
and tv awards
how does it feel to be here to be in
person
on a red carpet it's incredible i mean
i'm just excited
that i'm around people that i haven't
seen in a long time and also just like
not having to feel so i guess worried in
a way there's like a sense of relief you
know
we are kind of getting back to normal
and it's fun to be here with tanner too
i love that i need to ask about your
look because do we have
jewelry on around what is actually a
part of the spirit
can you show us oh my gosh
you look amazing did you guys coordinate
the all black chic looks in a way a
little bit
not like too intentionally but i feel
like we definitely like had a little bit
of
yeah i think we just read each other's
mind my mind reading
i feel like you guys have become so
close on this project
we talked to you not too long ago about
this we finally have a release date
what are you most excited for for
viewers to see
as they watch this movie when it comes
out in a few months um
i feel like well i guess we put a lot of
hard work into it
um i think everybody did specifically
even trying to shoot it through pandemic
yeah and i think also to just
trying to stay true to the original but
make it our own
uh i think that was that's probably the
most rewarding part
uh just to see people love it
i'm excited for people to see who's all
that
i love that i i also liked you on
keeping up with the kardashians
oh yeah that was fun it was you teaching
kim at tick tock what did she teach you
in return
um honestly she just gave me great
advice i think
the entire family has just always been
so sweet to me and so loving and caring
and
just giving me advice on you know how to
keep my spirits up especially in the
tough times that come with
you know kind of being in under pressure
in the spotlight sometimes but they're
they're all amazing people and i love
them
i know your podcast is back when is your
reality show coming out
um great question i don't know i don't
know i mean
i feel like reality is a tough world to
get into
so i'm not rushing into anything but who
knows maybe one day okay
before i let you go courtney and travis
are my absolute favorite couple on this
planet right now
i need your take on them i'm obsessed
i'm obsessed i love courtney and i love
travis they're amazing people and i wish
them the best they're so cute
speaking of obsessed when is your album
coming out
[Music]
no comment are you are you working on it
right now i mean i'm working
on a lot of different things with lots
of different songs we actually got into
the studio together
a collaboration a duet but um
yeah no i'm working on a lot of things
i'm super excited for people to hear a
little bit more
vulnerability from me and a little bit
more storytelling autobiographical songs
who knows
okay good to see you guys thank you so
[Music]
much